CONFIDENCE IN THE VACCINE.
STEVE: OKAY.
LET’S BRING IN JOE CONCHA, FOX
NEWS CONTRIBUTOR AND MEDIA
OPINION COLUMNIST FOR THE HILL.
JOE, GOOD MORNING.
>> GOOD MORNING.
HAPPY FRIDAY.
STEVE: THANK GOODNESS.
AND WE ARE MASKLESS ALTHOUGH WE
ARE IN NEW YORK SO WE STILL HAVE
TO WEAR A MASK BECAUSE THE
GOVERNOR HAS WHY COUNTY
ADMINISTRATION OUT OF NOWHERE
SAY HAPPY DAYS ARE HERE AGAIN
TAKE OFF THE MASK IF YOU HAVE
BEEN VACCINATED?
>> LOOK AT THE METRICS I WENT
BACK AND WATCHED AN INTERVIEW
THAT DR. FAUCI JUST DID A COUPLE
OF DAYS AGO ON CNN HE SAID
RESTRICTIONS SHOULDN’T BE LIFTED
UNTIL THE U.S. IS BELOW 10,000
CASES PER DAY.
SEVEN DAY ROLLING AVERAGE AS OF
YESTERDAY IS ABOUT 36,000 NEW
CASES PER KAY.
SO IF WE ARE HAVING MORE THAN
THREE TIMES THE CASES AND WE’RE
NOT AT WHAT DR. FAUCI, HE ONLY
RUNS THE CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE
IN TERMS OF HIS OWN METRICS WHY
WAS THIS DONE?
AS YOU SAID A VERY GOOD QUESTION
AND YOU WONDER ABOUT THE
POLITICAL ASPECT OF THIS WHEN
YOU CONSIDER THE GAS LINES IN
SOUTH CAROLINA MAJORITY OF OF GA
STATIONS ARE CLOSED OUTRIGHT.
PIPELINE SUPPLIES ALL THOSE GAS
STATIONS SUDDENLY GETS HACKED
AND PERHAPS A RANSOM SOME
REPORTS SAY WAS PAID IN ORDER TO
TURN IT BACK ON.
WHEN YOU CONSIDER THE MIDDLE
EAST IS ON FIRE IN ISRAEL AND
GAZA.
CONSIDER THE BORDER CATASTROPHE
WHEN WE HAD A RECORD NUMBER OF
MIGRANTS ENCOUNTERED IN APRIL.
THE HIGHEST NUMBER IN 20 YEARS
AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT INFLATION
AND THE IMPACT THAT’S HAVING ON
EVERY AMERICAN, YOU WONDER ABOUT
OLD SAYING ABOUT A DOG AND WAGON
AND TAIL AT THIS POINT.
AINSLEY: FULL MEDIA MELTDOWN.
HERE IS SOME OF THE DOCTORS ON
OTHER NETWORKS AND WHAT THEY HAD
TO SAY ABOUT THIS.
>> FRANKLY, I WAS SHOCKED BY
THIS ANNOUNCEMENT.
I THINK THEY WENT TO ONE EXTREME
TO THE OTHER.
THE MAJOR STEP THAT’S MISSING
HERE IS HOW DO WE KNOW THAT
PEOPLE ARE TELLING THE TRUTH??
>> THIS IS NOT A FREE FOR ALL.
I AGREE WITH DR. WEN.
>> I’M BEFUDDLED WHERE THIS
GUIDANCE CAME FROM.
I THINK THERE ARE A LOT OF STEPS
WE ARE MISSING.
>> PEOPLE WHO NEVER WANTED A
VACCINE HOW DO I GET THEM TO
WEAR A MASK?
>> THAT IS A GREAT QUESTION.
>> FEAR IS THE GREATEST
MOTIVATOR AND MAYBE FEAR IS THE
GREATEST MOTIVATOR IN TERMS OF
REASONS TO WATCH TV OR REASONS
TO CLICK ON A CERTAIN SORT OF
ONLINE PUBLICATION, FOR EXAMPLE,
THAT TALKS ABOUT COVID AND TRIES
TO FEAR MONGER PEOPLE AND THAT
WAS DR. LEAN.
IN A WEN THAT YOU SAW ON CNN.
SHE ALSO SAID THIS WHAT’S TO
STOP THE UNVACCINATED FROM
ENDANGERING EVERYONE.
HERE ARE THE STATS FOR YOU AS
RECENTLY AS A WEEK AGO NEARLY
85% OF SENIORS IN THIS COUNTRY
HAD BEEN VACCINATED.
95% OF CODY DEATH IN THIS
COUNTRY OCCURRED WITH PEOPLE 50
AND OLDER THIS.  IS ALL
ACCORDING TO THE CDC.
THAT’S OBVIOUSLY BECAUSE OF
CHRONIC CONDITIONS OR BECAUSE
YOU HAVE AN AGING IMMUNE SYSTEM.
WHEN SHE SAYS OH MY GOD THE
UNVACCINATED ARE GOING GOING TO
KILL EVERYONE.
THE NUMBERS SAY THAT SIMPLY IS
NOT THE CASE.
>> YOU DON’T NEED THE NUMBERS,
JOE, BY THE WAY TO BACK UP
COMMON SENSE WHICH SAID IF YOU
GET VACCINATED I DON’T NEED WHY
NEED TO WORRY BUT.
WHY DO I NEED TO CARE ABOUT WHAT
YOU ARE DOING.
I CAN’T BELIEVE THOSE PEOPLE
HAVE A D OR R BEFORE THEIR NAME.
HERE IS WHAT I WANT TO GET TO
WITH YOU, JOE, HERE IS WHY IT IS
IMPORTANT TO KNOW WHETHER OR NOT
SCIENCE IS GUIDING
DECISION-MAKING.
THESE SAME AGENCY ALSO CONTINUE
TO GIVE US GUIDANCE SPECIFICALLY
WHEN IT DOCUMENTS WHO NEEDS TO
BE VACCINATED CHILDREN, FOR
EXAMPLE.
THEY WILL CONTINUE TO GIVE US
GUIDANCE THAT WE SHALL NOT
QUESTION AND HARANGUE US IF WE
ASK QUESTIONS ABOUT IT NOW WE
ARE LOOKING IN RETROSPECT AT THE
GUIDANCE OVER MASKS WAIT, WHAT
WAS GUIDING YOU THERE IF NOT
SCIENCE?
I HEARD THE CDC DIRECTOR NOT
FIVE MONTH AGO, NOT LAST YEAR,
LAST WEEK TALKING ABOUT HOW A
2-YEAR-OLD MIGHT HAVE TO WEAR A
MASK IF THEY GO TO A SUMMER CAMP
OUTDOORS AND EVERYBODY OUTDOORS
AT THAT CAMP WHETHER THEY ARE
VACCINATED OR NOT, WHETHER THEY
ARE UNDER FIVE YEARS OLD OR NOT
HAS TO WEAR A MASK.
WE WENT FROM THAT TO NOW HEY, IF
YOU ARE VACCINATED EVERYTHING IS
OKAY.
BUT I STILL HAVE QUESTIONS.
I WANT TO KNOW IF MY 7-YEAR-OLD
GIRL HAS TO WEAR A MASK AT GIRL
STILL IF ALL THE TEACHERS ARE
VACCINATED.
WHY DOES SHE HAVE TO DO THAT?
IT’S COMPLETELY UNFAIR AND
STARTING TO GET A LITTLE WARM
AROUND HERE.
ARE GOING TO GET UNCOMFORTABLE
AS WELL.
MORE QUESTIONS THAN ANSWERS
RIGHT NOW.
DR. FAUCI WHO NEVER MET A
MICROPHONE HE DIDN’T LIKE NEEDS
TO START DOING INTERVIEWS TODAY
AND PEOPLE NEED TO START
CHALLENGING DR. FAUCI AND NOT BE
SO AFRAID TO DO IT AND ASK JUST
BASIC QUESTIONS THAT INFORM
AMERICANS, PARTICULARLY PARENTS,
OF WHAT HAPPENS NEXT.
AINSLEY: JOE, I DID DO SOME
RESEARCH ON THAT BECAUSE IF YOU
HAVE A 5-YEAR-OLD OBVIOUSLY SHE
CAN’T GET VACCINATE SOD SHE WILL
PROBABLY STILL HAVE TO WEAR A
MASK AT SCHOOL IF THE SCHOOL
REQUIRES IT.
THEY SAY THEY WILL UPDATE
GUIDANCE FOR SCHOOLS AND SUMMER
CAMPS.
>> LOOKING FORWARD TO THAT
AINSLEY.
NO QUESTION ABOUT IT BUT HERE IN
NEW JERSEY, DID YOU GO INTO ANY
BUSINESS, I WAS IN SEVERAL
YESTERDAY, WAS AARON’S DAY.
I’M TELLING YOU NOT ONE PERSON
WASN’T WEARING A MASK, AND NOT
ONE BUSINESS WAS LIKE OKAY, IT’S
OKAY NOW.
I HAVE A FEELING IT’S GOING TO
TAKE A WHILE FOR PEOPLE TO GET
OUT OF THIS HABIT.
STEVE: I KNOW WHERE YOU WERE
YESTERDAY.
>> THAT’S CORRECT.
AINSLEY: SORRY TO INTERRUPT YOU.
I HEARD AGAIN AGAIN, I HEARD IN
NEW JERSEY YOU ALL HAVE A PLACE
WHERE YOU HAVE A HOME GOODS, TJ
MAXX, MARSHALS AND TARGET IN ONE
SPOT.
THAT’S LIKE A DREAM FOR ANY
WOMAN.
>> IF YOU ARE PRETENTIOUS IT’S
MARCHSHALLS AND TAR GET’.
STEVE: YOUR WIFE IS AN EMERGENCY
ROOM DOCTOR AND YOU MENTIONED
THE SCIENCE AS WELL.
YOU MENTIONED DR. FAUCI.
DR. FAUCI AS OF YESTERDAY COME
FALL SCHOOLS WILL BE WIDE OPEN.
EVERYBODY BACK FIVE DAYS A WEEK.
SO, YOU KNOW, AND FOR HIM TO
MAKE THAT CHANGE ON THE SAME DAY
THEY MADE THE MASK MANDATE
CHANGE.
YOU HAVE GOT FIGURE THE WHITE
HOUSE HAS BEEN DOING INTERNAL
POLLING AND THE NUMBER ONE THING
THE PRESIDENT HAD BEEN DOING
BEST ON WAS CORONAVIRUS.
PEOPLE HAD IT UP HERE.
POLLING GOING SOUTH.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
WE HAVE GOT TO PULL THE PLUG ON
THIS STEER THE SHIP THIS WAY
INSTEAD.
>> SO WE WENT FROM FOLLOW THE
DATA, FOLLOW THE SCIENCE, LISTEN
TO THE DOCTORS TO LISTEN TO THE
POLSTERS.
THAT’S VERY INTERESTING.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE BEEN SO
ACCURATE.
PARTICULARLY LAST YEAR, RIGHT?
PROBABLY NOT A GOOD IDEA.
AND BY THE WAY THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES AGAIN WAS
COMPLETELY MISLEADING IN HIS
STATEMENT YESTERDAY WHEN HE SAID
THAT NOBODY THOUGHT THAT WE
WOULD HAVE THIS MANY PEOPLE
VACCINATED BY NOW.
THEY THOUGHT WE WOULD GET TO
THIS NUMBER BY THE FALL.
NO, THERE IS NOT ONE PERSON IN
THIS COUNTRY DIDN’T THINK WE
WOULD GET TO THE NUMBERS THAT
WE’RE AT HERE IN MID MAY GIVEN
THE TRAJECTORY WE WERE ALREADY
AT WHEN MR. BIDEN TOOK OFFICE.
HE KEEPS MOVING THE GOAL POST
AND NO ONE BOTHERS TO FACT CHECK
OR CHALLENGE HIM ON THESE THINGS
IN SHAPE OR FORM.
AGAIN HARD TO CHALLENGE SOMEONE
WHO DOESN’T TAKE QUESTIONS.
STEVE: JOE CONCHA CAN MEDIA
REVIEW AND A REVIEW OF RETAIL
ESTABLISHMENTS.
AINSLEY: OUR NEW PILLOWS ON THE
COUCH CAME FROM THAT SHOPPING
CENTER.
WE APPRECIATE NEW JERSEY.
>> THANK YOU.
I WANT TO GO OUT AND BUY A
JAGUAR NOW I HAVE TO CALL IT A
JAGGY WIRE.
AINSLEY: WE ARE JUST REGULAR
FOLKS ON THIS CURVEY COUCH.
CAN YOU CALL IT JAGUAR.